how old were you when you made your
first feature film
i was 23 years old i had watched
kevin smith in high school a little
maybe 22.
i watched kevin smith rodriguez you know
richard linklater all these guys come up
like i made my film between seven
thousand and twenty five thousand
dollars i just
maxed my credit card sold my comic book
sold my car and then i
went put it in sundance and signed a
million dollar deal with miramax and
went oh that's all that's all it takes
i can come up with 25 000 and then fail
miserably
because what they leave out of all those
glossy stories is you have to make an
amazing movie
and making an amazing movie for no money
when you have no idea what you're doing
is
next to impossible so the people who
have done it are in some
very rarefied air and they're they're
where they are
because they had that raw talent and raw
ability right out of the gate
but what that gave me that i always say
failure is the best teacher
and that was you know we made a movie
that was passable and i enjoy it i'm
still very proud of it but
we had no idea how to sell it we didn't
get into sundance
what do you do then that was your one
and only goal uh
being a kid from canada you know living
living in the dark ages of like
limited internet and we didn't have
facebook and social media and film
freeway and all these wonderful things
to know about
a lot of these film festivals that exist
today didn't exist then like we would no
idea
what we were doing so it was a lack of
education and how the business works
a lack of understanding that just
because you made a movie
that has nothing to do with if people
will ever see it or buy it or
or even know it exists so yeah it was
it was a movie that it taught me the
basics of how to make a movie
uh it was creative it was fun uh it
excited me enough to go make another one
but it was uh it was a complete disaster
in terms of actually ever getting to
market or
making something that was of quality
enough for people to
to embrace what was it about it was what
three
it's called leaving town it was about
three young people
like just sort of post post high school
into college where life's just not
working out
for for three very different reasons
that all end up
just serendipitously running into a bar
in their hometown
and uh one of them's got a much darker
secret that he hasn't told the other two
and he proposes well we should
rob the local bank and leave town
forever
which they do and then one thing after
another continues to not work out and
the irony of the title is
they may or may not even get out of town
by the end of it and was
was it worth it to ultimately ruin their
lives
way worse than they they started with so
what did
your perceived failure of it whether it
was a failure or not
what did that teach you uh it taught me
that i was gonna have to learn a lot
more about the business and
how distribution works and like you know
we were shooting on the
the amazing camera at the time of the
dvx 100
you know that was the first camera that
came out that shot 24 frames a second
it mimicked film had a beautiful look to
it but it was still
pretty independent it wasn't 16
millimeter film it wasn't 35
involved a lot more post work than we
really knew what we were doing to
to achieve uh a quality look with it
but it was mostly the business end of
things just not knowing living in
windsor ontario canada and not knowing a
single person of
how to also had a very depressing moment
where
uh we had lightning it was we think it
was a lightning strike or a power surge
but something in our office
fried the computer and fried the hard
drive and the backup copy had been uh
recorded like that record over but like
copied over with wedding footage that
uh somebody at the company had like
filmed a family wedding with so we
didn't have the backup suddenly
so the film had to be re-edited from
from scratch
which was a major major setback and that
set us back a good
year year and a half because then we
could only edit it in
our spare time and got it finished again
and i think just a lot of people like
just
the love and the excitement was gone and
that's that's that's
a hard lesson to learn that like you
know if you're gonna commit to doing
independent film it's
years of your life you've got to be
there to the bitter end till every last
possible
interview sale you know screening
spending more money on film festivals
that was part of it too we've raised
enough money to make
the movie to shoot it but then you don't
realize how expensive
proper post is we hadn't researched that
or what it's going to take to
transfer to film to send the festivals
at the time
or even get the cost of submitting the
film festivals or traveling to them was
all things that were
beyond our comprehension and ultimately
was oh well
you can't really make a movie for 25 000
you can get it done but you can't
there's a lot more to it that
is necessary to get it out there did you
edit it
i did yeah oh okay even though i
co-edited it with a
that one i co-wrote co-directed and
co-edited so
i only had 50 percent of the the
heartache from that one
you